fourteen Emmy nominations for RuPaul's
Drag Race this year what's like the
group text with you and all the judges
when those numbers come out that we've
got 14 this year I immediately text Rou
and say oh my god oh my god I God was
like a rainbow number 14 and then I did
the same thing to Carson and Ross and
then I posted on Instagram because it's
such a moment of pride from me in
particular to have known Roo for as long
as I've known room it's been on so many
television shows with that that we've
been on together and radio and podcasts
and live productions that to see him
lead this into a life-changing
television program and to be part of
this legacy is such an honor and a gift
so it's all individual text to get fired
off yeah kind of group Chuck's me Ross
and Carson it's probably Ross Carson and
I we have a group text okay and that is
continual that goes on and on rose not
in that one because we would kill me we
were roaring I believe Haru has left the
group Joe will believe she will exit the
group chat yes and I'm serving up a new
season of fall stars 5 season 12 of drag
race is approaching it'll be your tenth
season right yes because I started
season Susan could you keep us apart and
you guys are really cranking them out
now how is this new batch gonna other
than new girls feel fresh well they're
fresh because they're new you know it
used to be when we started drag was very
marginalized it's changed a lot in the
years that I've been involved in
lgbtqia+ community so now you know the
girls are starting younger so they've
grew up watching drag race instead of
going to the clubs and painadu is doing
it that way old-school style
so we'll have some old-school style but
the new girls are different but they
haven't quite gotten their footing they
look great but they haven't been out
there performing so you know
everything's different everything's a
trade-off it's always gonna be fresh
because the talent is fresh
we also know it's gonna be fresh because
the British are coming the British are
coming
drag race UK is on its way how is that
different from drag race in America well
the premise is the same you got me and
you've got Roux and you've got great
Queens right I mean you've got Graham
Norton and Alan Carr doing the Ross and
Carson thing and they are amazing
perfect foils and for me
British drag in and of itself is
different it's fundamentally different
I'm gonna say it in the nicest way
possible they focus on performance in
that country and delivery and we perform
is on looks and attitude here in this
country so I think people are gonna fall
in love with the Queen's over there okay
and at first glance you might be like
but I'm telling you they are remarkable
you'll you'll be caught at first but
don't make the mistake of comparison is
everything we love about drag race us
over there snatch game make its way over
there all that I can't confirm or deny
but I can tell you that you will not be
let down with what we do because we're
gonna put six Roos there and on there
we're putting him through the same
rigmarole they are going through it you
stay ready you ain't got to give yeah
because these all these challenges
everything that you see the Queen's do
on our drag race is something that Roux
had to face in ruse life in career at
some point right that's where the ideas
come from reading ruse books hearing we
talk so that's what it's all about so
you will not be disappointed
we're just waiting to figure out how
will us viewers that well well presents
plus right speaking of British you are
doing the British version of Dancing
with the Stars what I thinking right
what were you thinking fifty for God's
sake this is what I was thinking I've
recently explanted my breast implants
and they were making me very sick and I
haven't been able to be myself for about
15 years I haven't felt like myself and
I'm a mother I'm a wife I work on
television I'm traveling a lot and I
thought what can I do to kind of
celebrate this new health second chance
at health new body turning fifty and
when they asked me I thought this makes
complete sense I want to be out there
for the women of a certain age that made
me feel like they couldn't do it when
they absolutely can cuz I'm gonna do it
and I know nothing about it and be
reborn with the new body and the new
person that I am so I'm gonna work might
off to be the best that I can be trap
things up here with the Emmy nominations
what would a win mean for this year
especially now you see the creative team
like Delta and Raven get honored and all
that what would a win for this package
of seasons mean I will tell you this
it's gonna sound like such pageant bull
poop right now but it's the
honest-to-god truth you've heard people
y'all heard people over the years saying
the nominations really the honor in this
world of TV if you think about it we are
over content açaí 'ti right now so with
all the people that they could choose to
give the nominations to the fact that we
have 14 really Bryce I swear to you it
really is an honor just to be nominated
if we get the win obviously that's
amazing if not we are in great company
and it has been such an incredible
season to have 14 nominations my hair
people my makeup people it's in my style
it's like these are my friends and to
see them be nominated and of course my
best friend as you know hosts an
executive producer and all the people
world of wonder it's an honor and I
don't know what's gonna happen
but we are so grateful for it
you